I had the police come to my house a full
cook in the morning and they said here
is a government it's called an Osman
morning an Osman morning is when there
is serious intelligence that people are
about to kill him then it goes on to
read what you're not allowed to do
you're not allowed to get a weapon what
am I supposed to do put a little chain
on my door all right guests long form I
want to have this guy we've been having
them on we've been having him on for a
while now it's been a while and now he's
just he's just blowing up poor choice of
words given the fact that many people
want to kill him and that's their
preferred method of taking somebody out
you can follow Tommy Robinson dot online
his twitter is there's a story behind us
I'm sure at Robinson parity so I'm sure
there's some kind of perma ban that
happened there he's everywhere mr. Tommy
Robinson thank you for being here sir
how are you I'm good absolutely I'm good
now what's the what's the story behind
Robinson parity do you look did you lose
your Twitter account yeah that's not me
well I don't know why I had it removed
first of all they give me a week-long
ban because I said that 90% of grooming
convictions when Muslim men grooming is
the gang gang raping of young children
in the UK now that's actually a fact 90%
are Muslim men 20% are called Mohammed
yeah they banned me for a week for that
and then they removed me for saying
Islam promotes killing people well it
would seem as though the statement
unfortunately aligns with statistical
realities and that is the problem with
the that's a trip with their algorithms
if you'd have just said you know for
example Tommy Robinson is a Nazi I think
you'd be well within your rights well
you've been here so first up before we
get into some some of the very specific
stories recently you you have gone
completely independent tell people what
that means and where people can best
find you and support you for a year
where I learned to see that the future
the future is bringing people or
bringing people I want people to see
what I see I want them to experience and
see the places and the problems that I
see the people
I talk to I wish on a four-bit 10 years
ago I wish I'd have been like everyone
else but I left rebel media I went on my
own so that I'm my own boss I'm in
control of the stories I run people can
follow me on Tommy Robinson's not unlike
I have plans to build a studio like the
self
I have plans as well to build to get a
double-decker bus a double-decker bus I
want to turn one side of into a TV
screen and I want to travel the UK
showing people what's happening in those
towns and seas so I'm making mini
documentaries about areas go into those
areas hopefully get out from alive but
show people truthfully this is what's
happening on the ground yeah well it
sounds like it's a super secret that we
have been building up here for for
stateside from we do the live shows at
schools because there's so much
equipment that we have to bring and
these live shows that we have to put on
a good idea if you can get that done a
double-decker bus did billboard for
death its Robinson well hold on before
before I continue I want to show this
one clip this is a recent video for
those of you who missed this a little
run in that he had with a Muslim man who
was threatening his life and we'll see
how it turns out
[Music]
now tell me when I watch that clip I saw
it
what struck me most is there as an
officer there right that looked like
there was a police officer he didn't
even have a problem with it because the
guy was running out threatening you like
this even in the UK it seems as though
you're well within your rights to do
that specifically he was going to kill
me I had been warned about going to that
area you know I went to Italy for the
elections and I spent an hour
researching what's happening in this one
scene and what I found was just I found
a Somalian man who went into a hospital
and whilst an Italian woman was in a
Hokkien bed having labour giving labour
up her baby he climbed on and raped her
I then found that an Eritrean man had
chopped up an Italian girl just two
weeks before murder doe raped and I
chopped her body up and left in a
suitcase
I found that 75 year old woman had been
raped just a mile from where I was
standing
Boyet by a Sudanese man I found
unbelievable stories horror stories the
only source story she'd would have
previously read about in Africa or in
South Africa or in the Middle East right
here in Europe I found one case one case
where a man a Polish man was with his
partner and a group a gang of Muslim
migrants see him up and then he mate
they made him watch as they gang-raped
his wife on a beach for hours they made
him watch and these were stories that
again it's just this is Europe now these
are stories that are commonplace in
every country in Europe I'm asking you
because some people say well why are you
focusing if you just go out looking for
a stories of Muslims who happen to
commit crimes
you'll find them statistically that's
not the norm and it just had their
election and the lega have gone from 4
percent to 80
percent the left had been completely
booted out of politics this was a
political revolution in Italy so I asked
why why is the country swell ladies
let's see what problems there are that
have resulted in the next coalition
government the leader of La Liga says
that Islam is incompatible with their
country and they will probably deport
six hundred thousands so I wanted to
know why they won the election let's
look at the problems let's look at
what's resulted in this and that's where
I started to find unbelievable horror
stories that were unthinkable crimes
that you haven't heard of on the shores
of Italy this commonplace yeah and then
we found a journalist a female
journalist who live on screen was
violently and sexually attacked and
dragged down the street noise what
report the news life by Muslim migrants
these are all migrants and and that's
the story that shocked me was oh for
those instances I just told you yes oh
for the pen convicted had been refused
and should have been deported from Italy
but they weren't so all of this was
failed to Simon's cases but they were
allowed to stay so all of these victims
could have been saved if the laws would
have been enforced and the guidelines
would have been followed but because
they weren't and that is why the Italian
people licked it a government a new
government that will remove the people
in power who have left their women at
Prague
it really is unbelievable that you
haven't heard of these stories the
people stateside certainly every but you
would think in Europe at least you think
it may I don't know at least the chyron
on BBC not at all not at all and you're
painted as a racist as a Nazi one thing
I think a lot of people don't realize I
mean you were raised in am i pronouncing
it correctly Luton yes just like when I
watch double-oh-seven
they say double-oh-seven why don't they
say why don't they say why doesn't why
doesn't Judi Dench say then I'm confused
they invented a language
so you're raised there and pretty
diverse area so a lot of your friends
growing up didn't look like you your
problem years with an ideology in the
systemic political corruption that
allows it to victimize people I've been
watching you for a while I think this is
your fifth time on the show when Pete
would come on small Han Tommy Robinson
he's erased do you know anything about
do you know where he was raised do you
know who his friends are
he just hates Islamic rape how is that
controversial Lukens one of the most
multicultural diverse towns in Europe
yeah if you if you've got all of my
friends together all of us are the sons
of immigrants
my mother was an Irish immigrant but
then other image would be solution
Jamaican all over the Caribbean Italian
Bulgarian Polish we are a town full of
immigrants but there's one problem in
our town it doesn't come to relax or
country of heritage the problem is split
ideologically through religion we've
never seen motional tensions we only see
religious tensions so yeah so when I
talk about these issues people say about
racism I've simply been used and I'm
glad that after 10 years now or 15 years
of combat in it people don't usually
associate that anymore people now
finally say he's against Islam right so
they pivoted to Islamophobia right but
they've tried to make that seem as
though it's a form of racism right now
especially state tuneups Islamophobia
race in wroclaw ii Islam is not a race
we have Johnny jihad over here from
state in the United States we have women
in the United States who its head jabs
blonde hair and blue eyes that people
convert to it it's the most converted to
a religion in the American prison system
why cuz it's going hey you hate and you
want to commit evil here here's a book
justifying your acts of violence that's
another big lie people don't talk about
that it's the fastest-growing religion
it grows it's exclusively by birthrate
and through the prison system that's it
nowhere else and for some reason people
on the news even there's a talk one of
the fastest growing religions in the
world but you also can't leave it that's
a good point so I like the Episcopalians
you're like all right well we'll still
see you at the potluck yeah I'll see you
at the potluck I'm just an atheist now
okay yeah you're gone if you don't
convert in prison you least you get a
nice pair of teeth on the state it's
true
exactly well I mean you did prison time
a long time so I mean this is one thing
I do want to and give you credit for to
an unbelievable degree a lot of people
out there hold themselves out as ballsy
people and I'm doing the stuff that
people out there won't do Tyler Robinson
was beaten within an inch of his life in
a
in the UK we've talked about that go
back to that interview he's out now and
he's been confronting people on the
street you did a video which I thought
was incredible
really merci yes real-life poker okay
Jame Robinson is death wish you found
this kid who had sent you death threats
and and confirm each oh the video here
and you confronted this person I just I
just foreshadow I said kid but I don't
think we didn't know as a kid when you
found him let's roll this clip and we'll
come right back
can I ask you what what is I've said or
done yeah they even if you didn't want
me murdered what what is about me or
what I've said that you so feel so
strongly against just just don't agree
with what you do can you give me one
example of what I've said or done that
incites hate well just just being a part
of the I do is a street protesting
against the whole of of Islam what
education you have on Islam now it
struck me Tommy first after do you know
this was a kid wait how did you find him
no so basically anybody talks about my
children that changes it yeah so I saw
these videos that he put online saying
I'm going to kill your family I'm going
to slit your mother's throat I'm going
to kill you okay I'm gonna rape your
door and then all of these things I said
said those yeah yeah made all of the
references he made we're about taking
the property so all of it was
religiously in point right what he was
safely which for me is a worry
especially with my three young children
so I then called the police my video the
meet with the police I said are you
gonna take this seriously they have
showed me they were they told me how
many different units and organizations
would what all over this so I said okay
fine I then went home but I was
uncomfortable sitting at home because I
knew what he said and I'd spent I put a
thousand pound reward up on Twitter to
say anyone who gives me your identity of
who this man is
I paid him a thousand pound I had seven
children who went to school with him did
you [ __ ] you about seven thousand pounds
Oh guys addressing when I met the police
I said here's his name here's his
address I've done your work well they
might not be so primed to help you I've
done your work I've done your job love
to do but it's true but it was it was
incredible I'm amazed knowing that that
context how civil you were with the kid
it really didn't seem like you were
trying to teach him a lesson at that
point
and not just be an aggressor I don't
think this kid knew what he was doing he
had no idea as to what it is that you
talked about that was so striking to me
we had the same thing at SMU kids
holding up protests protest signs that
weren't theirs and they couldn't tell
you a single thing I'd said do you find
that a constant when you confront people
who have this idea constantly with this
kid
I realized within seconds that he was
mentally ill within seconds of looking
at so I this could have turned out so
different i sat outside his house for
six hours watching his front door when
he's door open at 6:00 look in the
morning for him to go to prayer that's
when I caught him but then I was shocked
that 24 hours after I've sat down and
talked to the police who he is and he
pursed statement house ain't gonna go
kill an English lady he could have
killed an English lady he could have
killed my kids and they they got nothing
and then when I then it was very
apparent that he was a victim as well
was open about what he said he was a
mentally [ __ ] kid who has been used
and abused that's what he was he had the
minute I say he had them in late my
daughter's 10 I get more sense at my
door
when he asked me for an arm wrestle mid
argument an arm wrestle so it's very
clear that he did he had serious
learning difficulty seriously yeah but
he had a mental age for me whatever and
I asked him that the first one I said if
you got learning the police and he said
yes and it was clear that he did yeah
that's why I rang in an ambulance but
and if you look we've had free terrorist
attacks in the UK they've all been from
people with mental rickman mental mental
mental ages of young children yeah a
used of you sent out a bomb well I think
that's also important no because in the
United States we're talk about the
Second Amendment they just go mental
health mental health I'm Gohar psyche
and there are a lot of people with
mental health issues who aren't
aggressive but if you combine that with
an idiot
that actually encourages aggression just
like what's the prison system that
justifies actions just because someone
is depressed doesn't mean they lose
their right or weed right or weed well
good example I would imagine probably
with the prison stint that you had there
are probably some times where you felt
pretty down pretty depressed you could
have been diagnosed that way but if we
were what was that no no no I know but
you know maybe yourself but um the point
is that but you know you had a hard go
but in the United States you don't
forego your rights because of that in
the UK with no second Amendment right
how do you protect how do you do this in
in feel secure how do you protect
yourself at least in the United States
someone like yourself would have that as
a feel so if you keep your head in a
swivel but they can protect their own
and so can their family
you can't they're genuinely what is that
like I had the police come to my house
in the morning they woke me up and they
said here is a government it's called an
Osmond morning the Osmond morning is
when there is serious intelligence that
people are about to kill you they gave
me an Auslan morning and they said
al-shabaab
a terrorist group from Somalia Somalia
who two weeks prior had massacred
hundreds of people in the Kenyan
shopping on our Shabaab have main dudes
be caught killed all costs what you're
not then it goes on to read what you're
not allowed to do you're not allowed to
get a weapon
you're not allowed so basically what
I've said to them is what am I supposed
to do put a little chain on my door yeah
just told me and the police have given
me six of these six of these series
friends I had six Muslims who were
arrested in a car they had guns bombs
and IEDs suicide notes on the way to
kill me and I'm not allowed to if you
watch my videos for the past ten years I
walk with my hand on my back so when I'm
in a situation I did it in Rome and I
did it most recently against an Tifa
because I'm fed up of having my face
beam so but but I constantly have to be
not just not mom I not only have to have
a weapon to protect myself but I'm also
fully aware if I try to protect myself
I may end up in prison right for
fighting against for being a racial
attack right constantly not just
cautious of all of that I'm cautious of
all of it
I know only the Mayor of London just
cause for knife control just called for
knife control in London I don't eerily
guys already do have knife control I
mean what is it I have this right now
someone just just gave this to me as a
gift which would be totally illegal it's
just a stab myself that night yeah I
know it's strong spring yeah you know
now they're saying knife control I'm
going home on a second one when people
say it's just an assault weapons ban I
think we'll actually just it's just a
semi-automatic ban and they go well
actually it's a mental health issue well
actually it's a universal well actually
it's a gun registry then it will stop
well okay with your straw man woody you
think there's gonna be knife control it
sounds so absurd because what can you do
people have kitchen knives unless all
cutlery is plastic knives and forks
there is no way to implement knife
control on a general populace all of
light all airplane cabin right exactly
exactly all the life is near flame cam
yet that's what they've been calling for
in London I why why and how have they
not been learning from the mistakes
Tommy I watch it from here I first off
I'm very concerned that it comes here
the United States that's my concern
and I also cannot I genuinely I try to
understand people who disagree with me
so at least I can understand their
arguments I'm at a loss man maybe it can
help me well I've got three children
just bed every night and I'm aware that
people at some point are going to come
to kill me and I'm aware that I have no
way of defending my son and that is a a
gut-wrenching terrifying and also a sad
feeling there's nothing like it and
that's just so forget about going out on
the house I can't even defend them in my
house - and we have no way of having
weapons we're not allowed them you know
the noise you just pulled out yeah I go
to jail yeah I know something in Canada
by the way this isn't any more dangerous
in a kitchen knife that's something to
tabulate so if someone wants to come
into your house with a kitchen knife or
of course with a gun or a bomb or a
pressure cooker with some nails and they
can do it this is actually smaller than
the steak knives in our house
it's it's we don't have we don't have
firearms in the UK
there were 30 shootings in my hometown
30 in her four-month period so the
criminals still have guns right the
terrorists still have guns knife crime
Sadiq Khan the mayor he stopped stopped
and searched his his whole way to power
and what he claimed was to stop the
racist stop and search procedures of the
police since stopping that murders life
crime gun crime rape everything has gone
up upwards of 30% we just overtook New
York for more murders for the last two
months in our capital C than New York
London has become we London is the acid
attack capital of the world we have more
acid attacks in it in London yeah that's
something that really disturbs me like
to my to my soul there's one thing you
know shooting we were just talking about
this shooting knifing acid attacks
you're not even doing it with the intent
to kill you're just doing it with the
intent to ruin somebody's life that's
the only purpose behind it it is evil
just crystallize in one action I think
there's a special place in hell for
people and against women very very
commonly in the UK have you thought
about trying to get your sorry ass
stateside hmm I'd landed at JFK Airport
and I was held and deported and I was
told specifically I was deported because
the British said they didn't want them
to let me in so I come back in 2011 I
illegally entered America I received a
mops in prison for it oh jeez I come to
New York you know I come to New York and
I gave a speech as a warning to America
and I'll be honest I knew what I was
doing was wrong but I also felt the
moral the moral obligation to do it to
warn people in your country of what's
just happened in mine what I've seen in
my hometown far outweighed if I'm
morally right and I wasn't that bothered
about the law if I'm honest so about ten
bucks in prison for that in the UK spent
two days in New York if I don't know I'm
not I spent too much there yeah well you
know what you just have to go to a
sanctuary city and take up residence
that's what you do here illegally you
see you don't have an official mass - no
mustache hang out by Home Depot it is
amazing to me a lowrider and you're good
you Tommy
Robert you are the one person who has
been caught for entering the country
illegally and actually followed by going
I got in on September 10 2011 I go in i
go in through JFK Airport I was then
arrested six weeks later by the British
on the motorway in the UK I was
straightway reminded in prison and I
spent 22 weeks from solitary confinement
for two days in New York but my name was
Brenda laughs I found Isis fighters who
had done the same crime and none of the
winner Journal well this yes because
Nancy Pelosi said that would be mean
Tommy usually you don't listen I do
should never under enter the country
illegally but it's very easily to fly to
the hell hole that as Mexico and you
know Google Maps El Paso you're welcome
listen um
have you thought about going like to
Poland at least they seem to have their
act together Poland seems to be the one
place right now well now I guess you're
saying Italy I haven't been following at
a ton I know Lauren southern was
following that story but Poland seems to
be the one place it's kind of a just an
absolute turn of events where they're
going - no no we're not being beholden
to the politically we're not doing this
we're not allowing our culture to be
walls probably be yeah it's it seemed as
though Poland ain't taking no crap is
that the only place left Austria there's
a growing movement and a growing
grouping together of countries I went to
Poland for their Independence Day what
do you realize your Poland is permanent
was wiped off the map for so long right
they have polar - suffered under
communism Hungary Czech Republic these
countries know it's like to lose your
freedom to not have your freedom so
Reese so does East Germany that's why
the biggest resist
for that Italia for Deutschland
political movement it's in East German
because these people know what it's like
not to be able to talk about soap not to
be able to speak about and that's what
soap replace communism a visible Islam
and that's what we're now seeing and
these countries Viktor Orban is being
reelected tonight for his fourth term as
a leader of Hungary he was arrested in
1987 for opposing communism there's a
famous picture of him being held these
people know what it's like to fight for
their freedom I'm from a generation now
in Britain where and in Europe where we
think this piece that we have we think
this is like this has never been loyal
people have never had such an easy life
and and we're willing to give it away
because we have taken it for granted so
much that's what I see yeah by the way
this isn't the first generation to do
that that's the thing remember if you
remember the famous speech with Pearl
Harbor you know a generation of
Playboy's they thought America there was
a generation of Playboy's they did you
know been fattened up this generation
they were kind of post at this point
they were they were post Great
Depression they're send these younger
people in America had become sort of
stagnant this idea that they were living
a life of luxury they were boldly vows
and Pearl Harbor shook them up it only
takes one event you know that's the
thing it's just we've gone a long time
without it being a global catastrophic
event I guess I always thought that
maybe Europe since you guys all got kind
of screwed until we jumped in would
would have remembered it a little bit
more but no it really is remarkable
that's one constant that I noticed with
what you do anyone who watches your
content again Tommy Robinson dot online
they would know the people who hate you
don't know you address Islam the
political ideology that it is and we see
that happening we see it with actual
Sharia law and courts across Europe
people here say that won't happen here
it's happened it has happened it has
just a political prescription as it is a
religion it's not the same as
Christianity it's not the same as
Buddhism it's not the same as Hinduism
it's not the same as any other religion
and so when people jumped on for example
ben Carson he said I believe that the
Khan he did the Constitution in the
Quran or he said the Constitution in
Sharia law I don't know exactly what it
was either the Quran or Sharia law he
said I believe they're incompatible
people jumped on him I couldn't think of
a statement that's more
Madrigal I and the people who jump on
him and the people who you said to come
up to oppose you and the people who
stopped me in the street they have no
idea what we even stand for and then
they have no education when I have
people come up to me to argue the point
for Islam and the first thing I ask them
is tell me what you know about the
Prophet Mohammed diddly-squat nothing
have you read the Quran know what you're
defending something you know nothing
about yet here you are
could have need nur I've looked in and
researched every point I'm talking about
and you're here to shut me down with
nothing but I think that Britain L and
Europe especially my country is so
primed and ready now more than ever the
response I get now in public is a very
heart felt and warming's respond for me
because after years have been slighted
or slandered in the media what I
sometimes laugh about I take enjoyment
in the fact that the government media
the police they've all done everything
they can to try to ostracize and destroy
what we say than Who I am and right now
I've got more support than I've ever had
so what's a good point I have noticed
that Tommy I've noticed that because I
will say for a while they were
relatively successful and I think maybe
this going independent and getting your
message out there I mean you're you're
all over the place I've seen people who
say I hate Tommy I've never but the guy
has brass balls and he's right about
this there are a lot of people whose
minds have been changed I think that's
because you can get directly in front of
them as opposed to before they're always
you're in the story from someone else
namely people who don't like you so
you've noticed that shift yourself on
YouTube
most people we saw Jack the CEO from
Twitter saying about conservative ideas
this week he retweeted an article saying
this is a great article that article was
about civil war in America where we must
silence the conservative ideas right now
that's what they're doing here so what
they want to be able to do they want the
media to slander us demon oil us
dehumanize us and attack us and us not
even have any way of replying or
responding or arguing or just clearing
just being able to say that's not what
happened this is what happened that's
not what I said listen to me
don't listen to what the media say I say
listen to what I say it's a very big
difference it is different let me ask
fitting of which I'd like to ask you
since obviously you're you're there I
guess we say stateside you say Europe
sign probably not we just say across the
pond
with with Lauren southern who was was
bit was banned from the UK what's what's
the story there because I know we
haven't had her on since then I don't
think I think it's been a while it's
been a while what happened exactly and
how was the situation remedied so our
plan our plan was to launch a media
channel that will cover the whole of
Europe that would look something similar
to Infowars but it would be hosted by
myself with Lauren
now obviously they're aware of what our
plan was and Lauren has been banned for
life from the UK she was arrested and
held under Article 7 of the Terrorism
Act she was held under the Terrorism Act
now what she did is she come to Luke
so I just want to make this clear it
seems to me that Lauren southern but not
terrorists are being held under the
Terrorism Act am I getting that correct
I don't tell pound blonde chick who
we've had 450 Isis fighters returned a
thousand jihadi brides have come back to
the UK we've just had a preacher who's
banned from preaching in Pakistan tour
our country we had a terrorist who was
one of the most recent cases last year
who was he tried to join Isis in Italy
he lived in Italy Moroccan living in
Italy he tried to join Isis they stopped
him he told them I want to be a jihadist
he did they then put him on the
watchlist
he then left Italy he come to London
they didn't stop him they didn't arrest
him they actually watched him as he got
in a van and he went and killed 9 people
but he wasn't stopped look don't worry
Lauren southern is not in the UK we're
all ok good Lauren constant I'm hearing
is that is is they say we're
fear-mongering right yeah they're
they're afraid of ideas
I'm afraid of bombs and rape on yes yeah
exactly I think I would say that's
I wouldn't I don't even know if that
classifies as a phobia I would say
that's a legitimate grievance i wigging
raped mercilessly on a beach and not
being a fan of it yeah I would say you
have a legitimate cause for concern
ideas Laurence Shapiro most dangerous
man
yes Ben Shapiro world's most dangerous
man so so Lauren is banned for life from
the UK that's a pretty serious ban you
can't move to the United States take it
out this is this is uh it's getting to
the point where what do you do what's
what's the next step you just keep doing
what you're doing in Europe and and
Lauren will do it Canada side we saw
that on the same week that Lauren was
stopped so I was Britney pay but she's a
journalist from America a social
commentator from America she was
arrested were her partner they were held
in a detention center in the UK for
three days Joe the reason they give her
why she was held and the port breast she
was coming to interview me because she
was coming to interview me
Judas who'da thought we could do it
through Skype Tolls take that you
English truancy officer pricks I mean
that's how I picture all English cops
truancy officers no trolling a baton
with I know they're not just like not
all Canadian cops or Mounties so the
reason was interviewing you I mean at a
certain point it does I hope people
watch this interview and see your
content and go alright there is a
bigotry of soft expectations there's a
bigotry of low expectations because
let's say I hate you
let's say I hate Lauren southern still
to ban someone from the country simply
for interviewing you you know I remember
when I first interviewed a Imam showery
first halfway to set up a whole separate
Skype account remember and everything it
was we got a whole different computer it
was the first time I ever interviewed
Dean Cain and Imam Schauder in the same
show now he's being double converted in
prison so yes well exactly but back then
this was about two years before he was
sent to prison and on air
he basically praised Isis and you talked
about Syria baseless ed I deserve to die
on air when he was talking about it he
said I deserve to die and he praised I
said I'm going hold on a second this guy
is speaking in the UK where people have
been arrested for speaking things far
for people someone was arrested for
doing a cover of kung-fu fighting and it
was considered racism because someone
hurried outside of a karaoke bar and
this guy just said he supports Isis and
wants me to die and he's gonna hang on
and go have himself a sandwich I
couldn't get my head right I don't know
what to do about it
I can't believe it this is a country
where I've organized so after that after
they stopped Brittany back buying the
journalist from interview me by the time
they deployed her three days later and
she walked out of the Austrian airport I
was waiting with a camera so as she
walked out I said well they have one
we've now gonna do that interview right
here and it's gonna be watched by a
hundred times more people have watched
it thousands of people and they stopped
martin Sellner coming moment so there is
a part generation identity that's not my
politics I'm not an identity rien I
thought so but what they did weren't by
stopping him he was coming to speak in
speakers corner speakers caught him in
the UK if you know about it it's 300
years of history some of the most
controversial figures in our history
have spoke there from Karl Marx and
Lenin to George Orwell it's the one
place in our country that we're supposed
to have free speech but now because of
Islam because it there's a mafia mob of
Muslims there they are now worried for
people who will talk about Islam go in
there so they arrest them they detained
them they deport them that's their
answer to it yeah now the week the week
after that I turned up at speakers
corner and I delivered his speech and I
delivered it took thousands of people
and it was it was a brilliant moment
fast if they like a real triumphant
moment yeah for free speech yeah that's
right but then so then since then then
Twitter of remove Dawson on the sick
from Maine I'm organizing a march from
speaker's corner - Twitter's offices
with my local over I'm hoping cam
McGinnis I'm hoping stefan molyneux lots
of characters lots of people because the
Battle of that a with Islam or a battle
to talk about Islam that's what our
battle is we're not even allowed to talk
about it right so now yet the issue of
free speech is so is such a pivotal
point now in Britain yeah we are people
can see what's happening
we'd be weird it's being taken away from
us well I get questions so often when we
perform on campus and people talk about
you in the first moment the Second
Amendment and I say
you don't understand one thing I was
raised in Canada and I brought you up as
an example before to I say free speech
doesn't exist outside of the United
States period a lot of people think a
little yeah nope nope and there's that
famous speech from the newsroom remember
with Jeff Daniel he goes you're talking
about what's right about America free
speech England has free speech Belgium
has freedom but no no they don't they do
not have the same kind of free speech
that you have just read Chris red light
is to say the same thing ran as free
spirit I'm like are you serious are you
do you think Japan has free speech by
the way Ghana laws you can't have a gun
highest suicide in the industrialized
world Japan who to know that you could
just jump on a 60-story a window kids
don't understand it and that's why I
hope if nothing I do not want you to be
a cautionary tale in the sense that I
really don't I really want this to end
well for you Tommy you've brought up
some things that obviously are
concerning and I feel I am worried about
you because I know how unsafe it is over
there I want you to stay as safe as
possible and anything we can do to help
you with that but I do hope that people
at least see what has happened to you
already with the prison what has
happened to you already with the speech
laws and understand it as a cautionary
tale that not only does freedom of
speech not exist outside the United
States not only are there people like
you out there fighting for it actively
but it could very easily go away in the
United States if the same kind of people
who've achieved power in Europe achieve
that here in the States because it's not
a slippery slope argument it's not a
straw man it is absolutely what they
believe in what they want here Tommy
amazing work that you've been doing give
everyone your plugs before you go I
really want people to check you out and
support you what we're doing all my
facebook page and I see we've got some
we've got some exciting things planned a
very exciting you know when they do
negative things to me when they make
those moves whether it be imprisonment
what they also do at the same time what
I take satisfaction it does it lets
everyone else who's watching see it
shows it shows how totalitarian they are
it shows the tyranny that's coming yeah
and America you need to realize a really
wake up because know the country I
thought I lived in prior to starting my
activism is a very different country to
I now know anything and those same
trends and problems
and grow and start watching your
universities I'm seeing exactly the same
it's going through your country yeah
that is absolutely correct and one thing
else I want to note for people out there
I can already see the comment section oh
is he triggered no no listen Tommy
Robinson doesn't just go out and say I
was banned on Twitter and [ __ ] about it
he then moved to another platform and
makes sure that he is active there is
nobody out there who whines less and
actually does more than Tommy Robinson
in the UK I recognize that I hope people
out there do when they're thinking of
who to support with their dollar plus
he's gonna give out 7,000 pounds next
time to anyone who finds his his accuser
70,000 pounds cash from his pocket Tommy
Robinson dot outlined thank you for
being here sir hey did you like this
video it what you didn't oh you're a cat
person well that makes sense
disregard him and or her /z everyone
else hit the subscribe button and leave
your comment below as to why you like
this video i you know what crazy cat you
can get back you couldn't you can
comment below to as to why you don't
like it